There’s no place on earth quite like Antarctica.
Its landscape alone sets it apart: a vast
white wilderness that can provide a haven
for solitude.
But Antarctica’s uniqueness isn’t just
its scenery.
Politically, Antarctica is also an anomaly.
There are no permanent inhabitants, no government,
and to date, no nation has successfully claimed
this territory as its own.
But with many outside nations eyeing its resources,
the question is, how long can Antarctica remain
ungoverned?
The people living here seem to be at peace
with themselves.
My name is Natacha Pisarenko.
I’m a professional photographer working
for the Associated Press....
My photos were taken in South Shetland Islands,
and in the Western Antarctic peninsula..
Natacha came to Antarctica to document scientists
who hailed from different fields and different
countries around the world.
And despite their different backgrounds, during
her time on the icy continent, what Natacha
observed was peaceful cooperation among the
researchers.
These relationships were established, and
codified, back in 1959, during the height
of the Cold War.
Antarctica is protected by a treaty as scientists
have to investigate Global warming and other
important issues.
What she’s referring to is The Antarctic
Treaty.
Twelve countries, including the US and Soviet
Union, signed the agreement, which states,
“Scientific observations and results from
Antarctica shall be exchanged and made freely
available”.
Overall, its goal is to foster international
relations and cooperative scientific research.
The treaty also means that no one “owns”
Antarctica.
And sure, some countries have tried to lay
claim to land here, but these claims have
never been universally recognized.
Today, there are about 75 research stations
here, maintained by various governments.
And all of the countries represented still
maintain the idea of cooperation that was
stated in the treaty 57 years ago.
But international harmony isn’t the only
draw here.
Antarctica’s pollution-free air allows for
air quality monitoring with a reliable baseline.
Dark winters attract astronomers, and ice
core samples can be analysed to provide a
climatic record for the planet that dates
back hundreds of thousands of years.
However, as Natacha realized during her time
with the scientists, all of this collaboration
can be fragile.
many fear that countries will rush to explore
its mineral resources and oil.
For now, countries are banned from drilling
or having military bases, but several nations
keep research stations as a way to claim territory.
We’re talking about as much as 200 billion
barrels of oil...which is perhaps enough to
at least ask the question -- could oil break
the peace here?
We might not know the answer until the Treaty’s
review in 2048.
Until then, Antarctica might remain the closest
thing we have to a Utopia.There have never
been any wars, nuclear testing, or any form
of military activity despite all the different
countries working here.
We can’t say nearly as much for anywhere
else in the world.
It’s a beautiful world, there are no borders,
and people rely on generosity and kindness
to survive.
I really hope it remains untouched, it’s
a key place for all of us, and where we keep
coming back to ask ourselves, where did we
come from, are we alone in the universe, what’s
the fate of our warming planet?
On the other side of the planet there’s
another isolated polar region at the center
of a geopolitical debate.
Check out this video on how The Bering Strait
could become a major trading hub on the scale
of the Panama Canal.
The agreement was established in the Cold
War era, when a group of scientists from 12
different nations convinced the UN to institute
the “International Geophysical Year”,
an event designed to promote scientific research
in Antarctica.
It’s success contributed to the Treaty we
know today.